[Musique]
l'histoire commence ici à porrentruy
la journée s'achève et pour baptiste la
ville une autre aventure débute cette
nuit cette élue au conseil de ville
phare pour la malaisie et la jungle de
bornéo un pantalon
qui se transformera aussi en pyjama pour
les musiques toujours pratique pour
éviter les piqûres et des insectes après
ce qu'il faut encore cédé des
chaussettes de foot pour se protéger
contre les quand les contres les
sangsues
pas vraiment
non c'est vrai pour pour aller siéger au
conseil de ville ou 1,6 g c'est pas tout
à fait le même matériel mais la preuve
en est c'est que ça ça l'est aussi donc
je suis pas je suis dans mon temps libre
et lui mais mon travail moi c'est c'est
de voyager beaucoup de défendre les
droits des populations autochtones de
malaisie
[Musique]
car baptiste la ville est avant tout
membre de l'association bruno manser qui
depuis les années 80 soutient les
derniers nomades de bornéo les peu dans
leur région la voici le sarawak un océan
vert défigurée par ces trous et orange
les traces des bulldozer
la forêt primaire a perdu ici 80 % de sa
superficie en 50 ans des milliers
d'espèces d'arbres remplacés par un seul
le palmier à huile
sur le chemin nous faisons cette
découverte salut c'est du poison il dit
que c'est du poison je vais vous dire
quel type de poison c'est ça noté ici
alors ici au thé glee pause à 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 vidon de glyphosate ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que les plantations de
palmiers à huile sa demande c'est des
monocultures et sa demande des quantités
mais invraisemblable de pesticides dont
le glyphosate ont fait partie mais il y
en a bien d'autres on a bien d'autres là
je prends une photo
comme ça j'ai l'évidence qu'on a du
niveau aa je vais aussi prendre un point
gps comme ça j'ai le point qui va avec
et quand on s'enfonce dans la palmeraie
le constat est sans appel c'est tout
brûler
la forêt tropicale humide hotspots de la
biodiversité mondiale
écosystèmes absolument remarquable ben
voilà ce que ça devient une fois que ces
importations d'huile de palme c'est à
dire que ça devient une monoculture déjà
mais en plus ça devient une monoculture
qui est terriblement mal
mal géré parce qu'on voit très bien il
ya quelque chose qui va pas c'est quand
même pas normal d'utiliser autant de
glyphosate pour pour ces quelques
palmiers qui sont ici
une industrie qui menace la vie des
populations locales deux jours après le
départ nous arrivons enfin chez peine
mais gouttes l'un des chefs nomades
ponant
demain on va on va boucher puis on va
aller on va aller un petit benoît fort
et je pense à ma taille tonte hana
high cube en bois
baigné gouttes et les siens comptent
parmi les derniers chasseurs cueilleurs
de bornéo ils vivent encore au coeur de
la jungle en harmonie avec la nature
dans ces modestes campement
chaque jour lui et son ami partout
chasser le gibier et les oiseaux à
l'aide de leurs sarbacane et de leurs
flèches d'empoisonner
des gestes précis et un regard tendu
vers les cimes ils n'ont pas besoin de
se parler pour se comprendre
que tu es l'accord de paix global voice
and win forêt intacte comme celle ci
nous permet de chasser et de trouver
notre nourriture il ya des sangliers
dessert mais au lit plein de pomone on
trouve ici tout ce dont nous avons
besoin pour vivre et faire vivre nos
familles
[Musique]
c'est vital pour nous d'avoir les arbres
et des rivières propres ni nos
traditions peuvent ainsi perdurer et
entre les nomades penaud et la suisse
une histoire d'amitié très ancienne
c'est en 1984 que bruno manser un
écologiste suisse apprend l'existence de
cette tribu dans la forêt tropicale de
bornéo il y vivra 6 en créera une
association avant de mystérieusement
disparaître dans la jungle en l'an 2000
tout le monde ici se souvient de lui
là je me souviens d'un homme qui allait
pêcher chasser avec la sarbacane
cueillir des fruits il aimait chasser le
chevreuil
qu'il savait tout faire
weng la femme du nomade là également
bien connu
je me souviens que bruno avait dit à mon
père si tu ne te défends pas contre les
incursions des compagnies forestières
tes enfants étaient petits enfants ne
pourront plus vivre et bien plus tard
mon père est venu nous parler à mes
frères et moi et on a organisé le combat
cette forêt aurait sans doute été rasés
et transformé en palmeraie s'il est peu
n'en n'avait pas résisté
[Musique]
à deux heures de marche du conte ment
aux limites du territoire de ces nomades
voici l'endroit où s'organisent leur
lutte un barrage à travers le chemin
forestier qui coupent l'accès au
bulldozer
a d'abord construit cette barrière
sans elle il n'y aurait plus d'arbres un
poison pour nos flèches plus d'animaux
plus d'arbres fruitiers
les eaux serait polluée et qu'à tout
cela cause de cette route d'exploitation
forestière ya la méthode mais la
barrière n'a pas suffi peng meghout a
donc été contraint d'utiliser la manière
forte il s'est uni avec d'autres nomades
de la région pour construire un barrage
mais cette fois ci en dur une maison au
milieu de la route
ils sont venus à cinq reprises pour
détruire notre barrière en bois
alors on a construit cette maison pour
obliger les camions des compagnies à
faire demi tour
et ça a fonctionné
les peaux n'en voudrait maintenant
porter plainte auprès de la justice
malaisienne mais le problème c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas encore de papiers
d'identité
baptiste la ville les accompagne dans
cette démarche
il leur apporte leur toute première
photo qui viendra parachever leur futur
passeport
camerounais aurait eu notre lot mais
tout me
dis que c'est très important il pourrait
d'avoir cette identité parce que au
travers de cette identité il valide le
fait qu'ils habitent ici
pour mener leur combat les pneus n'ont
pas le choix il doit faire avec notre
monde moderne et ses lourdeurs
administratives
c'est encore pas gagné non plus parce
que c'est vrai que c'est les formulaires
qui sont difficiles à remplir on le voit
un formulaire compliqué ils vont encore
chercher ce sont les signatures des
diverses personnes et voilà donc ces de
l'administratif et je pense pas que ce
soit le lephone ont plus d d
des des nomades des derniers nomades de
bornéo et au ballet hollande à ça va
permettre à notre village d'être reconnu
on est déjà 10 dans le village avoir
signé ce seront 10 personnes reconnues
par le gouvernement pavin pour défendre
un territoire il faut avoir une identité
c'est le premier pas
pour peine dégoter sa tribu il y a
urgence les dernières forêts sont au
coeur d'un intense spéculation de la
part des exploitants qui rêvent de ne
plus voir d'hommes pour défricher et
faire du profit
la menace des palmiers à huile plane
également ici à un jour de jeeps et
plusieurs heures de pirogue
au chaos et le chef d'un village situé
dans un corridor de forêt aujourd'hui en
danger d'un côté les montagnes du
sultanat de brunei et de l'autre le parc
national du moule ou classé patrimoine
de l'unesco où la chasse est réglementée
entre les deux une langue de terre
appartenant au plan sur laquelle les
industriels ont jeté leur dévolu sur
la balle ou et ça à la cause de
l'exploitation forestière
et les bulls et les souillés je ne peux
pas la boire
ici par contre celle où tel que l'a
toujours été regarde moi je peux la
boire
face à cette pollution ou chaos est lui
aussi entré en résistance avec ses
hommes ils ont dressé ce camp en pleine
forêt une base qui leur permet de
veiller jour et nuit sur leur territoire
et elle les problèmes ont commencé quand
la compagnie est venue pour nous
annoncer qu'elle allait s'installer ici
qu'ils allaient tous coupés pour
transformer l'endroit en une palmeraie
mais cette présence ne suffit pas
le lendemain matin une simple sortie à
une centaine de mètres du camp montre
l'ampleur des dégâts des arbres
centenaires arrachés et abandonner
cet arbre s'appelle le wissam yahia
devaient tâcher l'orignal est à contrer
bois nous sert d'appât pour la pêche et
il est essentiel à notre survie et ça
aide maintenant mais il est détruit
l'étonnant avait pourtant obtenu de ryan
lagoon l'une des plus importantes
compagnies forestières de malaisie le
gel de la déforestation sur cette zone
mais la réalité est tout autre la c5
tiens on entend le bruit des bulldozers
et la brayelle avaient dit qu'ils
arrêtaient
tous des menteurs
on va aller voir
derrière la colline un cimetière de
grumes du bois tropical dont la vente va
permettre à la compagnie radial lagoon
d'empocher plusieurs millions de dollars
une fortune dont les paiements ne
verront jamais la couleur et pour savoir
à qui est destiné ce bois baptiste la
ville a une idée là j'ai un tracker gps
avec une autonomie très longue et on va
le placer et comme ça on saura où ce
bois fini et on sera six filles dans une
scierie en malaisie ou bien si ces
grumes partent en europe ou en chine
une fois dissimuler le boîtier va
enregistrer les moindres déplacements de
cette grumes pendant presque un an et
sur toute la planète
c'est un travail aussi vite qu'on va
dire c'est une liberté celui qu'on a
c'est de savoir s' est contrôlé un peu
le travail des entreprises les
entreprises ont des responsabilités et
je pense que la société civile doit
pouvoir aussi se donner et se donner les
moyens de vérifier
et la récolte de preuves va même plus
loin
à lèvres d'un drone baptiste la ville
cartographie minutieusement chaque
kilomètre carré du territoire prenant
pour documenter la longue liste des
promesses non tenues des compagnies
profusion de pesticides arbres abattus
sol à nu une catastrophe écologique mais
à la clé des cartes qui seront
essentiels pour les communautés locales
vous voulez en même temps un ces cartes
vont permettre de délimiter notre
territoire et d'indiquer tous nos
repères importants de sucre ont pourra
ainsi décider de frontières et protéger
notre espace une tâche longue et
délicate mais baptiste qui se rend au
chevet des paiements depuis dix ans
puise son énergie dans la détermination
du chaos et des siens je regarde du côté
des communautés locales je regarde leur
engagement leur imagination pour
défendre leurs droits pour défendre leur
terre et donc ça ça me donne beaucoup de
confiance en l'avenir
il faut savoir c'est qu'ils défendent
leur terre pour leur intérêt mais leur
terre c'est l'oxygène de l'ensemble de
la planète c'est la biodiversité c'est
un patrimoine mondial qui sont en train
de sauvegarder pour nous
dans les prochaines semaines c'est peu
nan construire ont à leur tour une
maison barrages et porteront plainte
contre le gouvernement du sarawak un
long combat pour une planète qui respire
[Musique]